acts of terror can be carried out in a
whole variety of ways but they can be
boil down to two distinct types the
first is what the militant groups call a
spectacular that would include attacks
like the twin tower bombing on 9/11 the
Mumbai attacks in India and the Westgate
shopping center in Kenya they're
designed to cause as much damage as
possible and to kill as many people as
possible in many ways they're much more
like an actual act of war the second
type of terror is perhaps even more
frightening this is when individuals or
small groups carry out indiscriminate
attacks on any type of target that they
so choose car bombs and obviously the
suicide bomb perhaps the most
frightening of all now Russia has got a
real problem with this since the 90s
have been nearly 2,000 individual
attacks of this nature and it's killed
nearly 3,000 people there is another
variant it's not peculiar only to Russia
but they have a big problem with it and
that is women suicide bombers and
they're known as the black widows
the terror attacks are almost always
linked to Islamic groups in Chechnya and
Dagestan the methodology is simple
touring around cities like Moscow
suicide teams choose lightly targets the
metro and all varieties of mass
transport are difficult to defend so two
tourist spots and even rock concerts
basically anywhere with lots of people
soft targets easy hit more women carry
out terror attacks in Russia than any
other country in the world here at the
Dubrovka theater in 2002 850 people were
taken hostage
the terror group was made up of 41
people 19 of them were women the terror
group was eventually killed along with
118 other theater goers what al-qaeda
and other terror groups around the world
have realized is that women are a very
useful weapon because they can get
nearer to the target than men certainly
they can get nearer before they're
checked and the other reason that they
want to use them is for propaganda when
a woman carries out a suicide bombing
attack people are genuinely shocked and
the question is why would a woman go and
do this they then start looking at the
causes behind why she's carried out that
attack and that is the winning of the
propaganda game that is when the
terrorists are on top
were these women attackers are known as
black widows because it's thought
traditionally at least that they were
indeed the widows of Islamic militant
fighters who had died usually in
Chechnya or Dagestan and that the
attacks they carried out - an act of
retribution against society here the
practice that nowadays most are actually
recruited and indoctrinated often in
camps in Dagestan and they don't operate
alone when they come on a mission a
suicide mission more often than not they
come with two or three Mentors
they make sure that they stay in the
zone so that they carry out an attack
and they make sure that they go to the
target that they have chosen and more
often than not it's one of those mentors
who will press the trigger that explodes
the bottom so Moscow and indeed the
whole of Russia is bracing itself for
another terror attack some analysts here
say that it is inevitable but I'm not so
sure
predicting when a terrorist attack is
going to take place is extremely
difficult to do and they almost never do
it
when it's expected nonetheless the
security forces are on high alert but
there is an old adage from terror groups
and it is very true the security forces
have to be lucky
every time the Black Widow attackers
need to be lucky just once